et on va plus loin avec aujourd'hui à
mes côtés christian makarian bonjour
christian on jouera frais quel plaisir
de vous retrouver avec j'ai également
parmi nos vilalta avec chronique
internationale à france 24 bonjour bilal
bonjour à faire il aura précipité la fin
de la guerre froide et fait basculer
d'une certaine manière notre monde dans
le 21e siècle mikhaïl gorbatchev est
mort à l'âge de 91 ans ses funérailles
se dérouleront samedi à moscou peu
d'hommes politiques auront connu un tel
destin lui dont le parcours s'identifier
à la chute du rideau de fer mais aussi
au démantèlement de l'ex empire
soviétique
c'est dire l'emprise qu'un dirigeant
peut avoir parfois sur le cours de
l'histoire même si lui minimise est
parfois son rôle et ses réalisations
écouté
par sa politique audacieuse il a marqué
l'histoire du 20e siècle michail
gorbatchev né fils de paysan dirige à
l'urss de 1985 à 1991 l'homme qui
voulait moderniser l'union soviétique
mais qui aura aussi provoquer sa chute
nous accordons beaucoup
je conseillerais à vladimir poutine de
partir trichereau il y a déjà eu trois
mandats de en tant que président et un
comme premier ministre pourquoi trois
mandats c'est suffisant des clans secret
autour de lui
voilà alors ce n'était pas le gorbatchev
que vous deviez écouter on l'écoutera
évidemment à celui là mais peut-être la
réaction aux mirettes gorbatchev si on
l'a japon évidemment le signal de la
régie sur ses commentaires à propos de
la chute du mur de berlin que beaucoup
d'historiens lui attribue
bien sûr que nous avons fait des erreurs
nous avons trop attendu pourrait former
le parti communiste
pourrait former l'union soviétique aussi
nous n'avons pas anticipé les problèmes
à voler
lorsque les gens ont commencé à gagner
plus et est à consommer plus le marché
n'était pas du tout approvisionné pour
répondre à la demande d'où ces files
d'attentes énorme dans les magasins chez
les gars voilà c'était le bilan de
l'union soviétique enfin bref moi je
vous lis que ce qu'avait dit mireille
gorbatchev à l'époque on a tendance à
exagérer la chute du mur il est vrai que
c'est un remarquable symbole mais c'est
surtout l'aboutissement d'un processus
qui a commencé cinq ans plus tôt les
premières élections libres en russie la
fin de la doctrine brejnev mon cher
christian les premières élections libres
sauf que celui qu'en 1984 le parti
communiste d'union soviétique croit
porté à sa tête en raison à l'époque de
son jeune âge c'est justement cette
raison-là qui les pousse à le nommer
censé incarner la durée après les
disons-le et les présidences les règnes
éclair d'andropov et surtout constant
matches amicaux oui parce que c'était le
poulain ou tom drop of qu'elle joue un
grand rôle dans sur l'ascension et ça a
été aussi le poulain d'un homme qui a
disparu des mémoires mais qui est-elle
idéologues du parti communiste qui
s'appelait mireille souslov et d'un
personnage très près taciturne est très
obscur un véritable idéologues nos
gambettes chauffe passait pour
effectivement comme vous l'avez dit
raphaël le continuateur le là comme la
prolongation du site m rajeuni un peu
modernisé et c'est pas du tout ce qui
s'est passé donc là a commencé son
destin et au fond il est resté conforme
à cette ligne à ligne là il n'y a jamais
eu adéquation complète entre le
personnage qui était horvat chauffe et
le système de l'appareil d'état tels qui
l'entouraient c'est la raison pour
laquelle aujourd'hui par exemple la
dîmière poutine considère que c'est un
des responsables de la fin de l'urss et
poutine a tout dit lorsqu'il a prononcé
la phrase suivante
la fin de l'urss dit poutine est la plus
grande catastrophe géopolitique
mondiale au 20e siècle donc ça désigner
clairement gorbatchev on verra justement
ce que ce que les relations
qu'entretenaient les deux hommes il se
révèle en tout cas où il se révéla après
son sa victoire en 84 comme un vrai et
authentique sans doute réformateur bilal
qui présidera notamment à une
désescalade dans l'armement une
réduction bilatérale les arsenaux
nucléaires comme on n'en avait jamais
connu sous gorbatchev le monde 20 plus
sûres bah écoutez son son bilan il est
connu on à la fin de l'occupation de
l'afghanistan
1989 on a qui ne s'oppose pas à la
réunification allemande en
89/90 de fait aussi à l'intégration de
l'ex rda à la république démocratique
allemande à l'otan sachant que à ce
moment là l'urss avait cinq cent mille
soldats soviétiques en allemagne de
l'est ce juste pour vous donner un ordre
de comparaison vadimir poutine à la
veille de l'invasion en ukraine sur les
soldats qui l'avait masse à la frontière
on était à peu près à 150 me donc c'est
pour vous donner un ordre de grandeur il
faut ré écouter les témoignages des
stalmans au moment de la chute du mur de
berlin qui était persuadé que les chars
soviétiques allez allez venir les
écraser comme du temps du printemps de
prague comme du temps de printemps de
prague en 68 comme à budapest en 56
il y a alors il ya l'allemagne a aussi
là vous l'avez dit le traité start donc
le traité de contrôle des armes
stratégiques y compris de l'arsenal
nucléaire qu'il a signé avec le père de
george bush en plein george bush père
puisqu'il y en a deux c'est la guerre
froide le monde est terrorisé par la
possibilité d'une guerre nucléaire et ça
depuis des décennies et lui justement il
va apporter une vraie pierre là dedans
et d'ailleurs on a notre notre collègue
notre éminent collègue mathieu mabin à
new york n'hésitez pas à dire hier que
que si le monde n'a pas basculé dans le
cas où il le doit à la capacité de
gorbatchev et george bush senior à
dialoguer on peut encore ajouter la
résolution 678 du conseil de sécurité
sur la première guerre du golfe qui est
là aussi une première puisque l'urss ne
met pas son veto justement à à
l'intervention américaine donc oui le
monde devient plus sur v certainement et
c'est là le paradoxe de mikhaïl
gorbatchev plus populaire en occident
cochet lui en urss où ces réformes de
désétatisation la pérestroïka se heurte
aux pénuries on va ré écouter justement
ce qu'ils disent à ce sujet
je conseillerais à vladimir poutine de
partir trop il y a déjà eu trois mandats
de en tant que président et un comme
premier ministre pourquoi trois mandats
c'est suffisant des clans secret autour
de lui pour les russes christian mas
terrien c'est l'histoire d'un échec
gorbatchev même avec le recul il n'est
toujours pas réhabilités non il ya un
double paradoxe chez gorbatchev le
premier c'est qu'il passe et c'est ce
que le régime de poutine a construit et
avant le régime de poutine celui de
boris eltsine il passe pour le fossoyeur
du système communiste alors que
gorbatchev a tout fait pour sauver le
système communiste en essayant de le
moderniser d'ouvrir les portes de fer
entre un air frais il ne souhaitait pas
à la fin de l'urss il ne souhaitait pas
la disparition complète du système
communiste il souhaitait le moderniser
le mondialisée l'adapter à son époque ça
c'est le premier paradoxe le deuxième
c'est que gorbatchev passe pour beaucoup
plus héroïque à l'extérieur qu'à
l'intérieur de la russie où il est
parfois carrément détester pourquoi
parce que avec gorbatchev on lui a collé
sur le dos et ça y est le chin a
commencé il a été très habile la baisse
du pouvoir d'achat et l'effondrement du
niveau de vie mais alors vraiment
l'effondrement du niveau de vie de la
russie dont 50% de la population ap
trois ou quatre années après le départ à
la fin de l'urss 50% la population russe
et est passé en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté c'est énorme pauvre issement et
tout cela à converger vers gorbatchev
mais c'est très important il est à mon
avis essentiel de souligner que les
successeurs de gorbatchev
en fait c'est anti légende ou plutôt
long diaboliser et notamment poutine a
chargé gorath chauffe pour sauver le
système est alors qu'il aurait pu
charger le système est épargné
gorbatchev un stage choix idéologique en
mai portes en 1991 il n'y a pas à
l'époque outin il ya effectivement elle
si une président des ja de russie et ce
putsch oui qui auraient théoriquement pu
lui servir ce putsch avorté échoué qui
au final leur a malgré tout été fatal
comme il était fatal parce que
yalcin a été remarquable dans la
manipulation montant sur son chat et
s'opposant aux forces putschistes
en vérité tout ça a été assez orchestrée
mais gorbatchev a fait une révélation
terrible sur ces dernières heures dans
un film remarquable est paru l'an
dernier sur la chaîne arte c'était un
portrait de gorbatchev aujourd'hui oui
donc on voyait un homme assez pathétique
boulimique très fatigué et il a fait
cette révélation le boris eltsine ne
venait donner trois jours pour évacuer
ses affaires vie des ses cartons et
gorbatchev a donc pensé naïvement qu'il
avait effectivement trois jours
lendemain gorbatchev s'est rendu dans
son bureau et il a découvert que eltsine
et sa garde rapprochée était ivre mort
en train de vider une bouteille de
whisky c'est gorbatchev qui l'a dit dans
ce fameux documentaire d'arte et je
conseille d'ailleurs à tout le monde
c'est la dernière image vraiment un
carrelet qu'on a vu de gorbatchev et
sert nation de voir le dévoiement de
celui à qui il confie les rênes du pays
c'est s'en défendant sa complètement
muet et il a été dans une amertume
extrême à la fin de sa vie et je crois
que il ya un paradoxe qui ne fait pas
honneur du tout aux systèmes russes
d'entendre ce soit angela merkel dire
cette phrase un historique il a changé
ma vie c'est angela merkel qui le dit né
en r d un oui absolument pour autant il
sera resté fidèle ensuite en aux
intérêts russes vilalta rabais jusqu'à
l'annexion de la crimée de 2014 4e prix
nobel de la paix bah en fait c'est
exactement ce que christian makarian
vient de dire ça on le rappellera jamais
assez
que mikhaïl gorbatchev n'a jamais été
pour le démantèlement de l'urss enfants
en tout cas pour son effondrement et son
démantèlement lui pensait qu en
réformant cette urss il allait pouvoir
sauver finalement ce qui dans son esprit
et le choeur de l'urss donc la russie ou
plutôt les russies puisqu'en fait dans
la tête des russes y en a 3 la
biélorussie l'ukraine et la russie c'est
toutes les russies et éventuellement ce
vraiment ce noyau autour donc
effectivement si gorbatchev a pu
critiquer vladimir poutine et on en
reparlera il l'a critiqué mais sûr sur
le plan intérieur en fait sur le sol sur
la manière dont vladimir poutine gérer
le pays à l'intérieur en revanche sur sa
politique extérieure de la guerre en
tchétchénie à l'annexion de la crimée il
a jamais été contre est plutôt pourrait
d'ailleurs j'ai retrouvé ce qu'ils
disaient en 2014 au moment de l'annexion
de la de la crimée donc mireille
gorbatchev a dit joël cité si la crimée
à l'époque a été unie à l'ukraine selon
les lois soviétique sans demander son
avis au peuple donc ça il lui reconnaît
aujourd'hui ce peuple a décidé de
corriger cette erreur dont qui vit les
verts de nikita khrouchtchev voilà il
faut saluer cela et non annoncée des
solutions parce qu'ils s'adressaient aux
occidentaux c'est ça la façon de le
gorbatchev christian makarian qu'on n'a
pas voulu voir en occident la répression
contre les pays baltes par exemple dès
1991 lorsque le monde a les yeux rivés
sur la première sur l'irak de la
première guerre du golfe la guerre en
tchétchénie qui n'a pas franchement
qu'il l'a en tout cas lui pas
franchement déranger jusqu'à l'annexion
de la la crimée on s'est mépris en
renvoyant gorbatchev est un démocrate
pétri d'humanisme à l'occidentale on
sait pas mais prix mais on a manqué
comme d'habitude d'information de
clairvoyance sur l'état réel à
l'intérieur de la russie comme
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui dans la situation
présente on ne sait pas du tout ce qui
se passe on est très mal informé
monsieur gorbatchev a commis sûrement
une erreur
fatal c'est que en essayant de faire en
sorte en se raccrochant aux branches que
le régime soviétique ne s'effondre pas
comme un château de cartes il a
effectivement laissé faire un début de
répression dans les pays baltes
lorsqu'ils se sont soulevés mais aussi
il l'a laissé faire en géorgie et
en se comportant de cette manière là il
aa fois à la fois déçu les modernistes
nous n'allons pas assez loin et
fortement irrité les conservateurs en ne
réprimant pas assez donc finalement il
s'est retrouvé avec peu de supporteurs
se sont pourtant des hommes à lui qui
ont pris leur essor sous gorbatchev
leonid kravtchouk pour la pour la pour
l'ukraine où edouard chevardnadzé pour
la géorgie qui sont aux commandes de ces
pays lors de l'indépendance oui mais
c'était bel et bien une génération
maintenant on peut le dire est
respectivement complètement
intermédiaire parce que le système aller
vers autre chose dans un premier temps
une libéralisation extrême avec une
forme de liquéfaction c'est la période
yalcin et puis eltsine fait appel à
poutine il faut jamais oublier c'est la
raison pour laquelle poutine a toujours
tendance à charger gorbatchev plus que
eltsine puisque quelque part poutine est
redevable à eltsine alors qu'il n'est
pas du tout l'avis de gorbatchev et donc
il ya une première phase eltsine qui est
un peu la chienlit il ya une deuxième
base poutine qui est la reprise en main
il faut reconnaître moi je
l'interviewais mereiles gobal gérante
2007 et il m'a dit cette phrase
vladimir poutine a sorti la russie du
chaos oui alors c'est étonnant parce
qu'effectivement le l'estiment n'est pas
réciproque en effet gorbatchev est
toujours resté assez mesuré sur sur
poutine on entendait un extrait où il
conseille à poutine disons de quitter le
pouvoir après ses deux mandats de
président et son mandat de premier
ministre mais enfin il n'est pas allé
plus loin dans la critique en revanche
est effectivement vous l'avez dit
poutine qualifie à la disparition de
l'urss de plus grande catastrophe
géopolitique du 20e siècle c'est le sait
le bilan c'est l'homme gorbatchev qu'ils
condamnent derrière ces mots oui parce
qu'il a tout à fait intérêt dans son
système idéologique et dans la
construction du système poutinien il a
tout à fait intérêt à charger au max m
merrill gorbatchev a le chargé de tous
les péchés de l'effondrement de l'urss
il lui a épargné juste la question de la
crimée et de l'ukraine sur ça il s'en
est pris à la période avant gorbatchev
mais sinon outil n'a intérêt
objectivement et ça le rend populaire
puisque encore une fois l'effondrement
du niveau de vie pour beaucoup de russes
a correspondu à l'air gorbatchev donc
boutines ne va pas cesser et on l'a bien
vu dans les communiqués qui là qu'il a
fait ou qu'il a adressé depuis la mort
de gorbatchev il ya très peu de
compassion oui mais pas beaucoup de
sentimentalisme a en effet bilal tarabet
grand bat urcuit il s'est abstenu a
effectivement de toute critique envers
le pouvoir de vladimir poutine lui a
créé lui-même effectivement d'avoir
restauré et d'une certaine manière le
lustre d'antan de la russie met alors en
fait c'est assez un petit peu plus
compliqué que ça là la relation entre
les deux hommes puisque à la base quand
vladimir poutine accède au pouvoir je me
rallie gorbatchev lui est très content
il le vide salut il dit en 2000 poutine
est intelligent sérieux réservé bien
organisée j'aime bien les gens comme ça
sur la guerre terrible vraiment terrible
on s'en souvient tchétchénie
gorbatchev déclare quand même que
poutine était guidé par les intérêts de
la russie donc vice argent est ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure et enfin en
2006 il gorbatchev dit ceux qui
craignent les dérives autoritaires de
poutine ont tort et justement c'est à
partir du virage autoritaire de vladimir
poutine à l'intérieur encore une fois je
répète des frontières de la russie
vis-à-vis des russes que gorbatchev
commence à le critiquer alors entre
autres punchline il lui a dit il a
déclaré par exemple que russie unie le
parti de vladimir poutine était devenu
la pire copie du parti communiste que
l'on puisse imaginer il l'a traité de de
quelqu'un de susceptible sauf que en
gros à partir de 2014 si on veut dire ça
comme ça donc sur la dernière période il
ya eu à la fois un soutien de michail
gorbatchev sur la politique extérieure
de vladimir poutine et un silence
finalement sur sur sa politique à
l'intérêt merci bilal merci également à
christian makarian ans qui était avec
nous c'est la fin on va plus loin on se
retrouve dans un instant pour un nouveau
journal dans paris dira christ avec
[Musique]